Bonjour à tous,
je suis Ben de la chaîne Nota Bene
et aujourd'hui, j'aimerais vous présenter
le troisième épisode d'une série de programme
dédié à la propagande
que j'ai réalisé avec l'INA
l'Institut National de l'Audiovisuel.
Aller, c'est parti pour un épisode
sur la propagande
durant Mai 68.
À 10 kilomètres de Paris,
sur un ancien terrain millitaire de 32 hectares,
se dresse le domaine universitaire de Nanterre.
Une faculté des lettres,
une annexe de la faculté de droit de Paris.
12 000 jeunes gens et jeunes filles habitants
pour la plupart les 16e, 17e et 18e arrondissements
et la banlieue ouest,
y font leurs études.
1500 autres venus de partout en France
vivent dans la cité universitaire.
Depuis novembre,
grêves et manifestations se succèdent.
Il y a un peu plus d'un mois, les membres
de l'association des résidants de la cité universitaire,
l'ARCUN,
ont abrogé le règlement intérieur,
et décidé que désormais,
aucune entrave ne limiterait la circulation
dans les pavillons des filles.
Ils ont décidé ce soir là,
de passer de l'autre côté,
de franchir la barrière...
Et c'est ainsi que débute ce que l'on appellera
les "événements de Mai 68".
Ce point de départ, ces revendications premières
semblent dérisoires.
Et pourtant, le mouvement de Mai
allait embraser la France entière.
Les influences de ce soulévement
sont à chercher dans les lectures de ces étudiants
mais aussi dans les combats dans lesquels
ils se reconnaissaient
comme le combat pour la paix au Vietnam
et contre l'impérialisme.
Demandez "Vietnam", journal du Comité Vietnam national!
Contre l'annexion du suréalisme
par les stalino-chrétiens, demandez "Rupture"!
La culture politique de ces agitateurs est bien
évidemment un moteur puissant de cette contestation,
qui d'ailleurs s'étend au delà du cadre de l'université.
Il y a différents groupements
il y a des étudiants communistes
Il y a des étudiants
qui se réclament des Gardes Rouges
Il y a aussi le centre de liaison
des étudiants révolutionnaires
qui seraient plutôt disont trotskistes
Qu'est-ce que vous voulez faire?
- J'en sais rien
- La révolution!
- Faire la révolution, pour vous c'est quoi?
- Changer le maximum de choses dans les structures...
- Pas seulement un changement économique,
tout un changement idéologique.
C'est sans doute ça qui rend Mai 68 insaisissable.
A l'époque, personne ne comprend ça.
Pas même le parti communiste ou la puissance CGT
qui voit en ces étudiants privilégiés
des bourgeois coupés des revendications des travailleurs
avant de les rejoindre quelques temps plus tard.
Le 2 mai, décision est prise par le doyen
de fermer l'université de Nanterre.
Une décision qui finalement
jette les étudiants insurgés
au coeur de la capitale.
Là-bas, ils sont rejoints par ceux de la Sorbonne.
Elle aussi était en assemblée générale permanente
et avait fini de se faire boucler.
Le préfet Grimaud envoie alors
les canons à eau et les CRS,
mais la répression n'est pas aussi ferme
qu'elle aurait pu l'être.
Et ce pour une raison toute simple:
Ces jeunes sont considérés par le pouvoir
comme étant la future élite de la nation
et on ne tire pas sur les journalistes,
les professeurs,les politiques, les artistes
et les hauts fonctionnaires de demain.
Cette contestation et ce régime d'assemblée générale permanente
ne concerne pas que Paris
et s'étend bientôt aux facultés de province.
Chez les étudiants, à l'inverse de leurs collégues parisiens,
aucun incident aujourd'hui à signaler à Lyon.
La journée a été calme comme le montre ces images
prisent aux abords des facultés,
mais dans les amphis, on a discuté des récents événements.
L'UNEF et l'AGEL préparent pour demain
une grêve générale des cours,
en liaison avec le syndicat national de l'enseignement supérieur.
Et pour parler de la télévision et de la radio
qui envahissent alors les foyers français,
les étudiants ont un slogan:
"La police vous parle  tous les soirs à 20h."
Et en effet, dans les journaux de l'ORTF, un visage
revient réguliérement tout au long du mois de mai,
celui du préfet Grimaud, celui qui a géré la crise
et auquel le gouvernement ne fournit
que très peu d'instruction.
Un homme calme et mesuré,
qui n'aura de cesse de faire en sorte
de ne pas attiser les tensions.
Parce que nous avons eu de très
nombreuses manifestations au Quartier latin,
tout le monde le sait, tout les parisiens le savent.
Et au Quartier latin nous sommes particulièrement tolérants.
Il est certain qu'on va pas tenir
le Quartier latin avec la même rigueur
que les Champs-Elysées ou la Place de la Concorde
où il est nécessaire que l'orde soit plus rigoureux.
Au Quartier latin on tolére très facilement
et de nombreuses manifestations
et tous ces derniers mois il y en a eu beaucoup.
L'ORTF
(Office de Radiodiffusion Télévision Française)
alors sous le contrôle des hauts fonctionnaires
prochent du gouvernement
a mauvaise presse au près des insurgés.
On lui reproche, à raison, de se tenir
trop à distance des événements,
de ne pas assez en rendre compte
et quand elle le fait
d'accorder une place démesurée à la parole officielle
Étudiants, ne suivez pas les provocateurs.
Il y a quelques jours Monsieur le ministre,
vous aviez déclaré qu'il s'agissait d'une poignée d'agitateurs
qui étaient responsable du désordre actuel.
Si vraiment il n'y avait qu'une "poignée de trublions",
c'est votre terme que vous aviez employé,
croyez-vous vraiment que les manifestations auraient
revêtues l'ampleur qu'on a connu vendredi et aujourd'hui ?
Ecoutez, je crois que
il ne faut rien exagérer.
Les manifestations de vendredi et d'aujourd'hui
sont profondément déplorables,
profondément regrettables
mais elles sont loin jusqu'à maintenant d'avoir
connu, en ampleur et en violence
les manifestations qui se sont déroulés à Berlin,
à Varsovie, à Bonn, à Rome, à Alger, à Louvain
et même à Colombia pas plus tard que
la semaine dernière aux Etats-Unis.
Dans les journaux télévisés du 2 mai au 14 mai,
sur 13 heures à 15 heures d'informations,
on ne parlera des événements que 2 heures en tout.
Et sur ces 2 heures,
1 heure 30 sera accordée au gouvernement
et à ses fondés de pouvoir.
Des informations de l'ORTF,
réalisées par des journalistes non-grévistes,
des "jaunes" comme on les appelle
qui accentuent la propagande.
Du côté du pouvoir, on s'inquiète à l'inverse
du rôle joué par certaines radios dans
la flambée de la contestation.
Car même s'il est avéré que le discours officiel
est majoritaire sur les ondes,
le fait même d'accorder du temps de parole aux agitateurs
et donc du crédit, est perçu comme une complaisance coupable.
C'est ce qu'explique Georges Pompidou, alors premier ministre
au micro de France Inter.
Je ne peux pas
ne pas souligner le rôle
en pareil cas difficilement évitable,
mais néfaste
de radios qui sous prétexte d'information,
enflammaient quand elles ne provoquaient pas.
Entre la diffusion du renseignement et la complicité.
Entre le soucis de recueillir les explications des manifestants
et l'appel à la manifestation
Il n'y a qu'un pas.
Et qui fut franchi
parfois allègrement.
C'est radios: c'est RTL et Europe 1.
Du début à la fin de la révolte,
l'accès à l'information et l'accés à la parole
publique est un enjeu crucial.
Car si les manifestants étudiants
finissent par être rejoints
par une foule de travailleurs de tous les secteurs
et ce partout en France,
c'est que l'aspiration a plus de liberté
qu'ils portent depuis Nanterre
rencontre un écho certain dans toutes
les couches de la population.
Y compris chez les journalistes, dont le travail
est étroitement encadré.
Au point même que l'ORTF est touché par une série
de mouvements sociaux revendicatifs.
Rappellons que les journalistes de
l'actualité radiophonique
réunis en assemblée générale le 26 mai dernier
ont pris acte de l'engagement solennel de toute la rédaction
sans exclusivité, de lutter pour obtenir un statut
démocratique de l'ORTF
au service de la nation.
Les journalistes de France Inter
rappellent qu'en vertu d'une décision de
l'inter-syndicale des personnels de l'ORTF,
ils sont garants de l'impartialité de l'information.
S'ils n'étaient plus en mesure de garantir cette impartialité,
ils useraient de leur mandat et demanderaient à
l'inter-syndicale de déclencher la grève.
Il est vrai qu'à l'époque,
le contrôle des médias par le pouvoir
est grand.
Et que cela suscite bien entendu l'inquiétude
et la colère de la rue
mais aussi des rédactions de l'ORTF
et des députés de l'opposition.
Les scèances de l'Assemblée Nationale
sont alors retransmisent en direct
mais là aussi, hors de question de laisser aux
télévisions une liberté totale de retransmission.
Dans un instant, le président de l'Assemblée va
de nouveau déclarer la scéance ouverte.
Je voudrais vous signaler que
de temps en temps vous entendez le son en direct
de l'Assemblée Nationale
d'autres fois celui-ci est coupé
cela dépend du président de l'Assemblée Nationale
qui dispose lui-même d'un interrupteur de son
sur son bureau, ce qui explique que quelques fois
il appuie sur  ce bouton interrupteur
qu'il donne ou qu'il enlève le son
de l'Assemblée.
Face aux tentatives de censure
et d'intervention régulière du pouvoir
sur le travail des journalistes,
la contestation est telle dans les rédactions
qu'au sortir de la crise,
il faut trouver un compromis et couper des têtes
comme dans bien des révolutions.
Un certain nombre de mesures personnelles
viennent d'autres part d'intervenir à l'ORTF.
Monsieur Pierre de Boisdeffre a quitté ses fonctions
à la direction de la radio-diffusion.
Monsieur Émile Biasini a remis sa démission
de directeur de la télévision.
Quant à Monsieur Édouard Sablier
il quitte la direction de l'actualité télévisée.
Difficile de ne pas percevoir la caractère
révolutionnaire des changements
qui s'opère alors dans le relation entre pouvoir et médias.
Car Mai 68, ce n'est pas seulement un mois agité
c'est le début d'une nouvelle phase de la modernité
qui n'épargne aucun secteur de la société.
Lorsque Giscard et plus tard Mitterrand entreprennent
de libéraliser les médias
radio et télévision
il s'agit une fois de plus d'une tentative de réponse
aux questions primordiales imposées par
le mouvement de Mai 68 au pouvoir
en combattant dans la rue
et au coeur des rédactions
Aujourd'hui encore, se pose la question de la proximité
entre le pouvoir, le pouvoir économique
et les médias.
différement certes puisque les acteurs ont changés
mais se pose toujours avec d'autant plus de pertinence
qu'internet à surgit
et que rien ne sera plus jamais comme avant.
L'esprit de Mai 68 sera t-il ressurgir dans les rédactions
dominées à présent par les grands et puissants patrons de l'industrie?
C'est en tout cas une des questions à laquelle
devra répondre ce début de siècle
et une question à laquelle les journalistes eux-mêmes
devront apporter une réponse pertinente.
00:10:37,100 --> 00:10:39,100
C'est fini! On  espère que cet épisode vous a plu
n'hésitez pas à laisser vos retours dans les commentaires
et à vous abonnez pour ne pas laisser les prochains programmes!
Salut!